this is an eight news now breaking news  alert  just into the newsroom we've just talked  about this a few minutes ago facebook  says it will  not let former president donald trump  back on facebook and instagram remember  there was an independent panel that was  looking at whether to do this  the company banned mr trump from social  media sites back in january they claimed  the former president incited the  violence at the u.s capitol back in  january  critics had said they were worried about  first amendment implications of  continuing the ban  but as i mentioned this independent  panel says that he cannot be on facebook  or instagram  still we'll have more coverage of this  later on this morning